a lot of people firmly firmly firmly
believe that Barack Obama is running
this country right A lot of people think
that he's the do you disagree Shadow
president right now do you disagree do
you I don't I mean to be honest with you
I wouldn't mind him maybe being in a
decision room
and Biden making a phone call to him
versus Biden just kind of
sleepwalking through these decisions I
don't know
would you have a problem with Barack
Obama being in the room so to speak did
you see the Durham report yesterday did
you see who was in it tell me you didn't
say report you didn't see the the the
there's another Durham report that came
out from Direction This podcast we were
here about to talk about some friendly
stuff and you decide to take it this
direction listen this is what we shame
on you Adam we're supposed to talk about
who's the greatest boxer of all time we
were supposed to talk about he's on his
way
I like that
uh Michael I think you were going to say
something
well you see we came out in the report
that Obama knew what was he was briefed
on everything that was going on in the
whole Mueller investigation he was
briefed he knew that Hillary Clinton
said that set it up he knew everything
and kept and lied about it well you know
what's new they all lie but I mean while
he was out of office no
he was in office okay yes he was in
office
let me tell you something Obama
the disappointing thing for me about I
met Obama on a beach in Hawaii I don't
even know who he was I had seen him at
the Democratic Convention he gave a
brilliant strike crushed it amazing and
so I walked up to him you know we were
talking on the beach this was before you
know he was thinking about being a
candidate nice guy he said wow I would
have actually I couldn't vote because I
was a felon but I would have voted for
him that's how inspired I was by that
speech and I said you know what this guy
has got a chance to really unite this
country a lot of divisiveness here first
black president great he was a total
failure in that regard he he divided
this country more than anybody up to
that point I believe
you know I really do and it was a total
disappointment and then look
there were all there's so many of them
are dishonest but uh is he running the
party I don't know about that I don't
know I mean I think it's just a lot of
his influence
but I also know from what you hear from
what I always told that him and uh Biden
don't get along he didn't like a he
didn't like Biden really yeah he didn't
like him this is what I heard and you
know there's a part of me that kind of
uh uh based on what Michael just said
right now is
if you're if you're Obama do you want uh
Biden to run again
I don't know let's just say you are
running things you want him to run again
do you you want somebody else to run
yeah you know I I don't think Obama even
Obama wouldn't want Biden
I mean Patrick this guy let me ask you a
question in your wildest imagination did
you ever believe that this country could
deteriorate so so quickly in two years
under anybody
I mean in my opinion well I mean listen
the goat was Jimmy Carter right yeah and
he eclipsed the coat I never thought
that was going to happen I'm in America
because of the goat Jimmy Carter you
know Jimmy Carter what they did to Iran
Kissinger himself it was a mess right
you know the whole economic hit man
throwing a country uh it's people
against its ruler its leader without
there being a real reason the country
had Advanced the way it has for decades
uh more freedom for women you know they
had a say they had a voice
marriage went from being eight years old
13 years old 15 years old it was more
becoming like you know uh uh an ambone
Carter comes and does what he does there
and then u.s's and shambles interest
rates you know gas prices oil and then
you thought nobody was gonna do it worse
than him then shows a guy named Joe
which by the way if you listen to Joe's
talks 20 years ago 30 years ago you're
like
this guy's funny he's Charming yeah he's
charismatic I actually like listening to
the way he would speak in the 80s 90s
now don't get me wrong of course uh I'm
aware of all the speeches that he
literally replicated or duplicated exact
words that was said by this person or
that person or this person from various
countries not even in the U.S but you're
like this guy's actually saying you can
represent right today seeing what's
going on with weaponization with the
economy with the way things are being
handled it's a little weird it's a
little weird we're going to see what's
going to happen so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]